as the world comes to terms with an
outbreak they hoped would never come
authorities are trying to figure out how
to best protect health care workers
during her time when they're needed most
covered 19 has led to a shortage of
supplies and medical staff say they're
running out of testing kits and
protective gear needed to help patients
it could be some combination of we don't
have enough shields but we have enough
masks so we don't have enough masks but
we have enough shield it's prompted
online users to help Jeffrey Zhang's
factory has started producing two
million face masks a day for medical
staff in New York his next challenge he
tweets will be distribution while panic
buying has led to empty shelves in some
places fears are growing there isn't
enough food to go around grocery stores
are lending a helping hand by
designating specific hours to senior
citizens and disabled customers to shop
and volunteers are stepping in to assist
the elderly people are able to submit
requests online for grocery delivery
pharmaceutical deliveries whatever it is
that they need from outside if they
don't want to go out and we send a
volunteer to pick it up for them we make
sure to minimize physical contact so all
money is split under the door the
groceries are left outside that concern
echoes across borders this restaurant in
Berlin closed a few days ago but the
chef and staff are working to prepare
dishes for nearby hospitals we thought
people will work for 18 hours and sleep
on their desks or in the waiting room
how will they be taken care of how can
we make sure they eat well and stay
healthy and then max said hey I can't do
much but I can cook while schools have
shut in Georgia in the United States bus
drivers are still on duty ensuring
children get a hot meal while parents
are at work our main focus is to see
that the children are fed no matter who
they are and musicians have set up
washing stations to protect the homeless
while you're doing our part to ensure
that people have access to this basic
necessity during this pandemic for many
who are in sulfus elation there's a need
to keep spirits up with song
[Music]
he's still got it or a message of
appreciation to those during the crisis
to all our health care workers we salute
you it's unclear how long this global
pandemic will last but human connection
and the kindness of neighbors goes a
long way
Rahila muhammad al jazeera